[Music]
everyone's getting beauty and glam what
is like a beauty secret that you do you
swear by every single day I swear by
preparation-h under the eyes does it
really worry does it does it's really
nice for tightening it up under there
backstage you've got girls doing prayer
circles some taking selfies others
applying makeup while sitting in the
sink but how did the contestants prep
for looking perfect in a swimsuit
the secret is butt glue it's kind of
like spray-on double stick tape to keep
things from riding up your backside
incredible another secret rub Vaseline
on your teeth to make them shiny and to
keep them from sticking to your lips
what's the thing that you do every
single day never fail meditate the more
you meditate the calmer you feel and I
think that's the that's the energy you
send out to people and that's what makes
you beautiful I make sure to drink like
1/2 a gallon to a gallon of water a day
to make sure that my skin always looks
hydrated at all times julianne hough is
back as co-host and executive producer
of Sunday night's live event what's the
message she wants the show to sin it's
all about you know being confident and
beautiful and it's not just a beauty
pageant but it's owning who you are as a
woman
you